[MUSIC PLAYING]
INTERVIEWER: It gives
me exceptional pleasure
to introduce Professor Claude
Cohen-Tannoudji of the College
de France for the
special seminar
that we're having
today in honor of his
having won the Lilienfeld
Prize at the American Physical
Society.
The Lillienfeld Prize is
awarded to a scientist
of exceptional distinction in
science and also in the ability
to communicate
science to others,
and I won't labor
the appropriateness
of that prize since I think
that will become self-evident
during the course of his talk.
I would like to talk a little
bit about Claude's background,
because we've been
friends for many years.
And I have known and appreciated
his work for many years,
and admired it, and admire the
tradition from which it comes.
It is the tradition of Alfred
Kastler, who essentially played
the pivotal role in
reconstructing science
in France after World War II,
who pursued a life of interest
in the interactions of
atoms with radiation,
and set a style for teaching
and for lecturing which
has influenced his
school, the Ecole Normale
Superieure, and who established
a tradition of which Claude
Cohen-Tannoudji
is the inheritor.
He has passed on
this tradition--
many of you have heard
his students speak--
Serge Haroche, for one--
Alain Aspect who technically
was not a student but worked
very closely with
Claude in recent years
is another exemplar
of that tradition.
Claude's work has been concerned
with the interactions of atoms
with radiation from his
graduate student days,
when he attacked the
problem of light shifts--
which were then a very
mysterious effect,
which were confusing
people involved
with precise optical
pumping experiments.
And out of those studies,
eventually came his theory
of the dressed-atom theory.
It really sounds so
much nicer in French--
[FRENCH]---- but in English
it's the dressed-atom theory.
And this is a picture
which is now widely used
to discuss phenomena,
of atoms, and radiation
and many other phenomena too.
So this whole new way of
looking at quantum systems
was developed by Claude.
In addition, many
of you are probably
familiar with his name
through his books--
his famous textbook
on quantum mechanics
and more recently two
monographs on quantum optics
and interactions of atoms,
the radiation field.
The latest one, of which, had
just been published in English,
I am sure you're going
to be the standard works
in these areas in the future.
Claude is at the Ecole
Normale Superieure,
but actually he is a professor
at the College de France.
And this is all too
complicated to explain,
but I do want to point out
the uniqueness of being
a professor at the
College de France,
because of it is the most
demanding institution
in the world for a teacher.
It is a demanding
institution because there
are no examinations that it
gives, no grades that it gives,
no degrees that it gives,
and no students that it has.
Now you might think this makes
it all very easy, but it isn't.
On the contrary, it
makes it very demanding,
because the lecturers
at the College de France
are open to the public,
and people come simply
because they want to learn
and not because they have to.
And if you are not
a good teacher,
you lose your audience, and
this puts a tremendous strain
on the teacher, I think.
At least, I couldn't conceive
of trying to really attract
my audience willingly week
after week and, in fact,
year after year, because there's
another rule there that very
few of us would put up with.
Namely, you do not
repeat your lectures.
Each year's sequence is
a new series of lectures,
so it is for these reasons
the most demanding institution
the world for teaching.
And Claude is one of the great
teachers at the College de
France.
His lectures there are packed.
People come from wide
areas around to hear him,
and without saying more
I think you will see why.
Claude.
TANNOUDJI: Thank you very
much for your introduction.
Before starting, I
would like to tell you
I'm honored and happy
to be here again in MIT,
because I was here in '76.
I spent some sabbatical
stay in MIT and Harvard,
and it's, for me, a
very great pleasure
to be here for a few days.
And I would like to
express my warmest thanks
for Dan, who, immediately
after the announcement
of the Lillienfeld Prize,
invited me to give one
of these lectures here at MIT.
Thank you very much, Dan.
My lecture will deal with
photon-atom induction, which
as you know play an essential
role in atomic physics,
and that can be considered from
two different points of view.
First, they provide
information of atoms.
They can be considered as
a source of information,
because by looking at the light
which is absorbed or emitted
by atoms, you can
get information
on the structure
on energy levels--
that the main-- the whole
field of spectroscopy.
There is a second
point of view, which
is that this interaction can
be used for acting on atom
and for controlling
their degrees of freedom.
In the '50s, '60s, as
Dan mentioned to you,
in the group of Alfred
Kastler and [INAUDIBLE] there
have been a lot of
experiments where
exchange of angular momentum
between atoms and photons
were used to control the
internal degrees of freedom
of an atom as a field
of optical pumping.
Now more recently during
the last ten years,
a new field is exploding,
which is called laser
cooling and trapping.
And one uses it is
laser light to control
the external degrees
of freedom of atoms--
the velocity and the position.
And what I would like to
focus in on in my lecture
is this second point of view.
I would like to show you how
it's possible to manipulate
atoms with photons.
And I would like
also to show you
that there is a certain
continuity between these two
lines, and how optical
pumping turns out
to be a very important aspect
of laser cooling and trapping.
My lecture will
be the following.
I will first give you a few
examples of processes where--
one uses photon-atom
interaction for controlling
the polarizations, the
energies, the velocity
of the position of an atom.
All these effects use the basic
conservation laws of energy,
and angular momentum,
linear momentum,
and are just a
simple illustration
of quantum mechanics.
Then in the second part,
I will describe a more
recent development
in this field,
which allowed us to cool atoms
to the micro Kelvin range.
And to get what we
call now cold atoms.
And I will describe,
mainly, two effects--
two cooling mechanisms-- the
so-called sisyphus cooling
mechanism and the velocity
selective coherent population
trapping which results
from an interplay
between optical pumping, light
shift, and radiative forces.
And finally in the last
part of my lecture,
I would like to discuss a
few possible applications
of these cold atoms, and
I've chosen two applications.
First are caesium
atomic clocks using
Zacharias atomic fountain.
And I am particularly happy
to see because of that
here because Zacharias was
trying to do such a scheme here
some time ago.
And the second example will
be a gravitational cavity
for neutral atoms.
So let me start with
a few processes.
And the first one will
be optical pumping,
which is a transfer
of angular momentum
from polarized photon to atoms.
As you know, the
angular momentum,
which is carried
by a photon, depend
on the polarization of light.
If you take a sigma
plus light propagating
along the z-direction,
the photon
associated with this light
beam carry an angular momentum
plus each bar with
respect to this axis.
Suppose that this beam is
resonant for an example
of atom, which is
contained in a cell.
And suppose, to
simplify and correspond
to actual experiment,
the atomic transition
connects a ground state
to be the angular momentum
1/2 to an excited state with
an angular momentum 1/2.
So we have two Zeeman sublevels
in the lower state and two
Zeeman sublevels
in the upper state.
The sigma plus light can
excite only the transition
between g minus 1/2
and to e plus 1/2,
because when the atom goes
from this state to this state
it gains an angular momentum
delta m equals plus 1.
It goes from m equals to minus
1/2 to m equals plus 1/2,
and these angular
momentum is provided
by the absorbed photon--
sigma plus photon-- so
only this transition
is excited by the atom.
Then when the item is an excited
state after a short time, which
is a lifetime of
the excited state,
it falls back to the
ground state either here,
in which case it returns
to the initial state,
or by emitting a
pi photon, delta m
equals zero in which case
it falls back in g plus 1/2
where it remains
trapped, because there
is no sigma plus transitions
starting from g plus 1/2.
So at the end of
such a cycle, atoms
have been pumped from here
to here via e plus 1/2,
and they have gain on the
average an angular momentum
delta m equals plus 1.
And if the absorption time
due to the collision of atoms
on the walls is
long enough, it's
very easy to put nearly 100%
of the atom in this state.
So that optical
pumping mechanism
is a very efficient method
for polarizing atoms
with 100% efficiency.
Now I'd like to emphasize
another important point
that such a scheme is also
a very sensitive detection
method, because as you
can see on this picture
only atoms in g minus 1/2
can absorb sigma plus photon.
So by measuring the absorption
of the light beam of the amount
of remitted light,
you have a signal
which is proportional to the
population of this level.
Now if all atoms are accumulated
here, the vapor is transparent.
Now you can-- if you apply
a static magnetic field
along the axis,
introduce the z match
splitting between
these two states,
and apply an resonant
radio frequency
field which induces radio
frequency between the two
Zeeman sublevels.
Usually, magnetic
resonance is detected
by the absorption
of the RF photons,
but you see here that any RF
transition bringing the atom
from g plus 1/2 to g minus 1/2
can be detected not on the RF
photon but on the subsequent
absorption of an optical photon
from g minus 1/2 to e plus 1/2.
So we have an enormous
amplification factor,
because it's much easier
to detect an optical photon
than an ideal frequency photon.
This is why such methods
have provided the possibility
to study a very
dilute substance.
Now you could see now--
ask two questions.
I have taken here a
resonant light beam.
What happens if the light beam
is slightly off resonance?
I've taken the light beam
along the magnetic field.
What happened is
the magnetic field
is no longer parallel,
but perpendicular,
to the magnetic field?
I would like to study,
now, these two cases
and to show you that interesting
things have happened.
First let me
consider what happens
if the light beam
is perpendicular
to the magnetic field.
It's called transverse
optical pumping.
You see that if the
light beam was alone,
atoms would be optically
pumped in the plus x direction,
and they will be
prepared in a state which
is the eigenvector of gx--
the component of
the angular momentum
along the x-axis,
which is, itself,
this linear superposition
of g plus 1/2 along z
and g minus 1/2 along z.
But that's not the
whole story, because you
have now a competition between
optical pumping, which prepares
atoms in this state,
and the larmor
precision around the magnetic
field, which makes this beam--
this magnetic moment--
persisting around
the [INAUDIBLE] with
the Larmor frequency
proportional to b0, omega
l, Larmor frequency.
So you have a competition
between two processors
with different symmetry.
So if you want for a given
value of the magnetic field
determining what is your steady
state orientation in the ground
state, you have to
sum the contributions
of all atoms which
have been optically
pumped in the path of t.
That is to see for t minus
tau with tau postive,
and which a time t has
not yet been disoriented
by collision or by absorption--
which have survived
all relaxation processes.
So what you have to
do in the x or y plane
is to consider atoms which
have been just pumped at time t
equals--
at tau equals zero times t, and
which are oriented along x with
a magnitude 1-- let us take 1--
and then atoms which had
been pumped at time tau
before which are rotated
by an angle omega l tau--
and which have survived
relaxation process,
so their contribution has been
decreased by e to the minus
tau over tau g is the relaxation
time of the ground state.
And then you have to integrate
over tau from zero to infinity.
And you see that
in this case, it
is clear that you have
two limiting cases--
the case where during
the relaxation time tau g
the larmor rotation is
very small in which case
you have to make the
vector here sum of vectors
which are nearly parallel.
So you get the large value of gx
and the small value of gy which
is roughly omega l tau g--
and the second case where omega
l tau g is much larger than 1
in which case all the
vector you have to sum
are nearly isotopically
distributed--
in which case gx and
gy is equal to zero.
And you see that your
critical value of the field
is field set that omega l tau g
is of the order of one radian.
So if you plot the steady
state value of gx and gy,
this is omega l.
You see that you have an
absorption shape for gx,
a dispersion shape for gy, and
the width of these two curves
is delta omega l--
where delta omega is said that
the corresponding delta d0--
delta omega l is such
that delta omega l
tau is of the order of 1.
If you take a cell with a
very good relaxation time,
let us see one second.
And if you take a paramagnetic
atom in the ground state 1
megahertz per gauss, this
width a magnetic field
correspond only to 10
to the minus 6 gauss,
so you see that this is
nothing but the Hanle effect.
But the Hanle effect
in ground state,
where because the lifetime is
much longer than in excited
state, the [INAUDIBLE] resonance
squared are extremely narrow.
And actually, we observed
such effects a long time ago
on 87 rubidium with Jacques
Dupont-Roc and Serge Haroche.
And let me give you,
here, an example of Hanle
curve in the ground
state of 87 rubidium.
You see that the width
is 1 micro gauss.
The signal to noise
is about 10 to the 4.
So if you put here the--
if you put yourself here
and you vary the film,
you see that you can
detect, very easily,
a fraction of nano
Gauss, so that's
a very sensitive magnetometer.
I think its sensitivity, which
is comparable to the screen.
And we choose this
at that time that
was using just ordinary lamps.
And actually, this magnetometer
was sensitive enough
to detect the static
field produced
by a gas of oriented nuclei.
One takes a cell of
10-centimeter diameter filled
with optically-oriented helium 3
nuclei with the density of 5.10
to the 15 centimeter cubed in
100-centimeter-cubed volume.
And we put the
rubidium cell nearby,
and we make the Hanle
resonances on this cell.
And we detect the field--
the macroscopic field produced
by this oriented nuclei--
nucleus, a very small
magnetic moment--
at the macroscopic
descent of 10 centimeters.
And to make things
with more fun,
we apply a very small magnetic
field to the helium nuclei
in order to have them
processing with a Larmor
period of a few minutes.
And that the field we
detect on the rubidium cell,
and you see a very good Larmor--
detection of the
Larmor frequency
three hours later
and 11 hours later,
and we still see
the nuclei rotating.
Actually, this experiment is
done in a magnetic shield,
and we tried to apply it to--
to see the magnetic field
produced by [INAUDIBLE],,
but the magnetic shield was
too small for introducing
even a baby in the sheaf.
But now it's great.
It's currently used to measure
the magnetic field produced
by the brain or by
the [INAUDIBLE]..
Before leaving
this experiment, I
have described it simply
with magnetic moment,
larmor position.
We can give a more
sophisticated description,
not for complicating
things but because I
think it provides a
basis for understanding
a more modern experiment.
We have cooling atoms below
the recoil, in which is called
coherent population trapping.
Because suppose that
you have zero field.
If you have zero field, you
can take any quantisation axis.
Now if you have
zero field, you know
that the atoms are optically
pumped in the direction
of the light beam, and they
no longer absorb light.
How can you understand that?
If you take the beam
along the x-axis,
and if you take, as a
quantisation axis, the z-axis,
a sigma plus beam along
the x-axis as polarization
which is a linear superposition
of the sigma plus,
sigma minus, and by
polarization along the z-axis.
So sigma plus along x is
within a constant factor.
Pi over z along z plus 1 over
square root sigma plus along z,
plus 1 over square root
of 2 sigma minus along z.
Now optical pumping
prepares atoms
in the g plus 1/2
x state, the eigen
state of x with eigenvalue
plus [INAUDIBLE]
2, which is a linear
superposition of g minus 1/2 z
and g plus 1/2 z.
So atoms are in this state,
and from these two states
you have pi, sigma plus,
sigma minus transitions.
But what is nice here is you
have a linear superposition
of these two states, and the
polarization of the field
is a linear superposition of
sigma plus pi and sigma minus.
And if you take
this superposition,
the amplitude for absorbing
a sigma plus photon
is the amplitude to
be in g minus 1/2,
which is 1 over
square root of 2,
times the amplitude for the
beam to be sigma plus which
is 1 over square root of 2.
And the amplitude of
absorbing a pi photon
is the amplitude to
be in g plus 1/2 which
is 1 over square root of 2--
and the amplitude for the
photon to be pi, which is pi.
And if you multiply
these two amplitudes
by the Clebsch-Gordan
coefficient
of this transition--
you easily find that the
absorption for sigma plus,
and the absorption for
pi, interfere exactly
destructively.
So the atoms are in linear
superposition of two states,
the photon is a
linear superposition
of two polarizations,
and the two absorption
amplitudes from
here and from here
to here interfere destructively.
And they interfere also
destructively from here
and from here to this
state e to the minus 1/2.
What?
STUDENT: What is pi?
TANNOUDJI: A pi is
the polarization
which is linear and
parallel to the z-axis.
The pi polarization with
respect to the z-axis
is the linear polarization
parallel to the z-axis.
There are three basic
polarizations for photons which
are sigma plus like that, sigma
minus [INAUDIBLE] if I take
the z-axis, and pi like that--
corresponding to the
three possible values
of the angular momentum of
the photon which is g equal 1.
STUDENT: I thought there
were only two levels.
TANNOUDJI: There
are two-- if you
take at the quantisation axis,
the momentum of the photon.
But a pi photon
is a photon which
propagates in the x
or y plane and which
has a polarization
which is linear
and parallel to the z-axis.
STUDENT: But are there
still only two states?
TANNOUDJI: A pi polarization
is a linear superposition
of sigma plus and sigma
minus, but it's called,
usually, atomic physics.
It's a transition
delta m because it's
called a pi polarization.
Now another important
thing here is
that in the old magnetic
field, the two states
g plus 1/2 and g minus
1/2 have the same energy.
So if the atoms is
in such a state,
it remains there indefinitely,
because this state does not
evolve.
Now if you put a
small magnetic field--
so if you have the
optical pumping along x,
and if you put a small
magnetic field along z,
the state g plus 1/2 along the
x-axis is still a non-absorbing
state--
an uncouple state.
But once the atom
has been put here,
this state is no
longer stationary,
because the phase factor
of applying the time
evolution for g minus 1/2 and
g plus 1/2 are not the same.
This means that the
state is evolved.
The state g minus 1/2--
g plus 1/2 is coupled to
the state g minus 1/2,
which can absorb light.
So I think the general idea we
can keep from this experiment
is that there are situations
where atoms can be prepared
in states which are
linear superposition,
and for which there exists
several absorption amplitudes
which interfere destructively.
That's a very interesting
quantum interference effect.
Now two situations
then can appear.
If the state is stationary--
if the states which
are linearly combined
have all the same energy,
an atom which is here
remains there indefinitely,
so all atoms will be optically
pumped in such a state which
no longer absorb light,
and the fluorescence stops.
But if you add a
perturbation such
that the states which
are linearly superposed
are no longer the same
energy, then the state
that's not stationary is
coupled to other states which
absorb light, and the
fluorescence reappears.
That's the main scheme of what
is called coherent population
trapping, and we will
see another application
of this effect later on.
Let me now give you
a second example.
What happens if the
light beam, which
makes the optical pumping--
which is now I come back
to longitudinal pumping--
what happens when
it is non resonant?
So I would like to
show you now that it's
possible to displace
atomic energy levels
by quasi resonant photons.
That's light shift or still
called AC stack shift.
And I would like to give you an
interpretation of this effect
in terms of dressed states.
Let me first consider
the uncoupled state
of the atom plus photon system.
For example, this
state is g n-- atom
in the constant g in
presence of n photons.
e n minus 1, this state is
the atom in excited state
e in presence of
n minus 1 photon.
If the laser
frequency omega l is
equal to the atomic
frequency omega a,
these two sets
would be degenerate.
If we are slightly
off resonance,
the two states are
not degenerate,
and the splitting
between them is
by delta, where delta is equal
to omega l minus omega a.
Now the atom in g can absorb
one photon and jump into e.
That means that the laser atom
interaction Hamiltonian VAL has
a non-zero matrix element
between g N and e N minus 1,
and this matrix
element is nothing
but each bell may go one
of two well omega 1 is
the so-called happy
frequency, which is well
known in magnetic resonance.
So these two states are coupled.
And it's well known
in quantum mechanics
that when two states are
coupled they repel each other.
This state is shifted down.
This state is shifted up.
And if we are in the
perturbative regime
where the coupling,
h bar omega 1 over 2,
is small compared to the
splitting, h bar delta,
we get the shift which is omega
1 squared divided by 4 delta.
And that is just
the light shift.
So you see that
the light shift is
proportional to the
light intensity,
because the square of
the high beam frequency
is proportional to
the light intensity.
Its sine dependent
on the tuning,
because it's 1 over delta.
If omega l is larger than omega
a, delta prime is positive,
its omega l is equal to omega
a delta prime is negative.
You could ask what happens if
omega l is equal to omega a.
Now we have two
degenerate states.
When you introduce
the coupling, you
get a doublet, an anti-symmetric
linear combination,
and that also is well
known in atomic physics.
It's the Autler-Townes
splitting of spectral line.
And finally, of
course, it depends
on the light polarization.
Actually, a light shift were
observed about 30 years ago.
This was the subject
of my thesis.
This light shift were called
lamp-shift by Alfred Kastler,
because they were produced by
the light coming from the lamp.
That was a play word for
comparing them with lamp-shift.
And actually, the experiment
was done on the 1/2 to 1/2
transition on mercury like
that, and the experiment
was done in two steps.
In the first step,
optical pumping,
when measured very accurately--
the transition frequency
between g minus 1/2
and g plus 1/2--
that's your green curve.
And then in the second step, one
adds a second beam of light--
second light beam--
consisting of light
coming from a different
isotope of mercury,
so it's shifted in frequency.
And this light beam can be
polarized either sigma minus
or sigma plus, and you see
immediately on this picture
that if it is sigma plus,
only g minus 1/2 is shifted.
If it is sigma minus, only
g plus 1/2 is shifted.
So you see that in one case,
you increase the splitting
between the two levels--
in those occasions,
decrease the splitting
between the two levels.
And this is what is
observed experimentally.
The magnetic resonance
gap is shifted
in the opposite
direction, depending
if the polarization of the light
is sigma plus or sigma minus.
Now I come to a
third example, which
is the transfer of linear
momentum from photon to atoms.
Suppose that we have a
laser beam, a laser plane
wave, and an atom in
a laser plane wave.
When the atom absorbs
the photon of the beam
it gains the momentum h
bar k, because each photon
has a momentum h bar k.
When it falls back to the ground
state by spontaneous emission,
giving rise to fluorescence
light, it loses some momentum.
But because spontaneous
emission can't
occur with equal probabilities
into opposite directions,
the mean momentum loss is
equal to 0 on the average.
So after a cycle, the mean
momentum change is h bar k.
And the mean force, which is
equal to the mean momentum
gained per unit
time, is just h bar k
dN over dt, where dN over
dt is the mean number
of photons absorb per unit time.
That is to say, the mean--
which is also equal
to the minimum number
of photons spontaneously
emitted per unit time.
And this is dN over dt can
be just written gamma sigma
ee, where sigma ee is the
probability for the atom
to be in the upper state--
population of the upper state.
And gamma, the
spontaneous emission rate,
which is also equal
to 1 over tau r,
where tau r is the relative
lifetime of the other state.
At high intensity and
for a two-level atom,
the atoms spend half of the time
in the upper state, which means
that sigma ee is equal to 1/2.
So the maximum
value of the force
is equal to h bar
k, gamma over 2,
and the maximum value
of the acceleration
of the deceleration, e max,
is just equal to f max divided
by m.
That is to say, h bar k
over m times 1 over 2 tau r.
If we put orders of magnitude
on this number, h bar k over m
is just the recoil
velocity of an atom
just after the absorption
of a single photon.
That number is very small--
3 centimeters per
second for sodium,
3 millimeter per
second for cesium.
Compared to the
terminal velocity,
which is a few hundred
meters per second,
that's a very small quantity.
But tau r is only 16
nanoseconds for sodium.
That means that you
can repeat this process
a large number of times.
And when you divide h
bar k over M by 2 tau r,
you get something
which is 10 to the 6
meters per second squared.
That is to say, 10 to the 5
the gravity acceleration, which
is a huge deceleration.
So that can be used to
stop an atomic beam.
You irradiate the laser beam by
your counterpropagating laser--
and atomic beam by your
counterpropagating laser beam.
If you start with
an initial velocity
of 1 kilometer per second,
with such an acceleration
you have just to
wait 1 millisecond
before stopping the atom.
And during this time,
the travel over distance,
which is a 4.5 meters,
which is not too big, so
we can do the
experiment in the lab.
And the only problem you have to
solve now is the fact that when
the atom is decelerating, the
Doppler effect is varying,
and you have to adjust the
resonant condition to maintain
the laser on resonant, and this
has been by different methods--
the first one which
was developed by Bill
Phillips' group was to change
the resonance frequency
of the atom by applying the
space dependent magnetic field,
the Zeeman tuning--
and the second one, which
is still simpler just
by chirping the laser frequency,
which is now very easy when
one uses laser diodes.
Just for illustration,
I'll show you
some research we obtained in
Paris on cesium by Christophe
[INAUDIBLE],, where
he plotted velocity
distribution of an
atomic beam initially,
which is the terminal velocity.
And after slowing
down one frequency,
the scan starting from here
to here, from here to here,
and leading to a
peak of true atoms
at 200 meters per second,
or 145, 102, 60, 17,
minus 8, minus 60.
A negative velocity means
that the atom had been stopped
and go back in the
opposite direction.
So if you adjust yourself
here between these two points,
you can have the atom stop
with a zero average velocity.
Now that does not mean that
these atoms have a zero
velocity.
They have a zero
average velocity,
but they have a dispersion of
velocity around v equals zero.
They have still a temperature.
Now I would like
to discuss, is it
possible to reduce
this velocity spread?
Is it possible to cool the atom?
Because the temperature is
related to the velocity spread.
I will show you now--
explain to you the simplest
possible cooling mechanism,
which is the laser
Doppler cooling mechanism,
which was introduced by Hamoch
and Schawlow for natural atom--
and by Wineland and
Dehmelt for free atoms--
and which can be
explained very simply.
You take an atom moving
with velocity v to the right
and irradiated by
counterpropagating laser
beams with the same frequency
and the same intensity,
with frequency being
tuned to the red--
omega l slightly
smaller than omega a.
If the atom is
moving to the right,
it gets closer to resonance
with this beam because
of the Doppler effect, farther
from resonance with this beam.
So the radiation
pressure of this beam
will be larger than this one.
The two forces would
not be balanced.
You will get a
total force which is
opposite to the
velocity of the atom,
and which for slow velocity
is linear in velocity.
So you will get a force
minus alpha v, where alpha
is your friction coefficient.
And the friction
coefficient is very strong,
and the damping
time is very short.
And this is why the
people from Bell Labs who
observed this cooling
mechanism in '85,
called the scheme optical
molasses, because everything
happened as if the atom was
moving in a pot of honey.
Of course, you cannot go
to zero by such a scheme,
because you remember this
friction can occur in a random
direction.
On the average, it's zero.
But from one process to another
it varies in a random way
so that in momentum space
the evolution of the atom
is random walk.
And exactly as in
Brillouin motion,
you have a competition
between two processes,
laser cooling which introduced
the friction coefficient alpha
which I've just described,
and momentum diffusion heating
which is due to the fluctuation
of spontaneous emission
and which can be described by a
momentum deficient coefficient
D. You can calculate
alpha and D,
and calculate your [INAUDIBLE]
temperature kB T Doppler,
and find it is D over alpha.
And you'll find, easily,
that this temperature
has a lower limit, which
is h bar gamma over 2.
That is to say, h
bar over 2 tau r,
which is reached when the tuning
is equal to 1/2 a line width,
and which is equal to 240
micro Kelvin for sodium
and 120 micro Kelvin for cesium.
So it's already a
very low temperature.
But actually, I would like
to make the following remark.
If you look at the famous
Einstein paper of 1917,
you'll find that there's
already a description of Doppler
cooling in this paper, because
he was considering how atoms
interacting with the
black-body radiation,
and exchanging linear momentum
with this black-body radiation.
Because of the
Doppler effect, we
are able to reach
temporal equilibrium,
so I think one can consider
the first discussion of laser
cooling is contained in
the 1917 Einstein paper.
Finally, I would like to
discuss your last example, which
is the control of the position.
Can you control the
position of the atom?
Can you trap the atom?
Several traps have
been proposed.
I would like to discuss one of
them, which have been proposed
by my young colleague,
Jean Dalibard,
in '86, which is called
the magneto optical trap--
and explain a simple case
of where g equals zero to g
equals 1 transition.
Atoms are put in
a magnetic field
gradient along the z-axis,
so the magnetic field
varies linearly with z.
The ground state which is
your m equal zero state
is positioned as an energy
which is position independent,
where the two states
e plus 1 and e minus 1
have an energy which
varies linearly with z.
And suppose that you
excite these atoms
with two counterpropagating
laser beams, sigma plus
and sigma minus,
having a frequency
omega l slightly smaller than
the atomic frequency omega a.
What happened?
Look at an atom, which
is going like that way.
When it arrives here
at this point z 1,
the frequency of the g0
e plus 1 transition--
that is the sigma
plus transition--
is resonant for the laser beam
coming from this direction.
So these atoms undergoes
radiation pressure
from this beam, and it
turned to the right.
It is repelled to the right.
When it arrives here,
it becomes resonant
with your sigma minus wave,
and it is repelled to the left.
And you see that the atom
is bouncing back and forth
between z1 and z2.
It's motion is limited
between two values.
It is trapped.
And in addition, you
have a combination
of trapping and
cooling, and these traps
are very convenient
because they work not only
at one dimension, as
I've explained here,
but also at three dimensions.
And also, they work in a cell--
not for a beam, but for a cell.
And they are deep.
They have temperature depths of
the order of 1 degree Kelvin.
And shortly after the
proposal, such a trap
had been achieved by a
collaboration between Dave
Pitcher and Steve Chu.
Let me give you an example
of such a trap, which
we have now in Paris.
That bright spot you
see here is a light
which is emitted by a cloud
of metastable helium atoms
which had been slowed down
by the magnetic tuning method
and which has trapped in
a magneto optical trap.
And you look here at
the fluorescence light
emitted by this trapped atom.
The scheme also work in
a cell, and here you have
the [INAUDIBLE] of 10
centimeter diameter--
the atoms are in the cell.
And the bright yellow spot
you see here at this point
is a cloud of cold cesium atoms
which are trapped in the cell,
so you can have now, in your
cell, cold and trapped atoms.
Now I'm going quickly to the
second step of my talk, which
is advances in laser cooling.
Around the '88, more
precise measurements
were done on the temperature
of these cool atoms, which
is not very easy to measure
the temperature of cold atoms.
And these experiments were
initiated by the Gaithersburg
group, and the big surprise
was the temperature
was much lower than expected.
Usually when you
do experiments, you
find results which
are worse than
the theoretical prediction.
Here, it was a
very good surprise.
The experimental research
results were much, much better
than the theoretical results,
and these quite surprising
results was confirmed
in Paris and Stanford.
Let me first explain to you how
the temperature is measured.
The idea is very simple.
You start with a
molasse, which is
a bowl of cold atoms like
that, and at time equals
zero you switch off
all the laser beam.
So the atoms are no longer
moving in a viscous medium.
They fly, and they
form a shower.
And you look at the light they
emit when they cross the laser
beam, which is located
7 centimeters below,
and you measure
the time of flight.
This time of flight is
determined by gravity.
It's determined by the
initial position distributions
that you can measure
by your camera.
You cannot show
that has been done.
Look at a slice in the
molasse by pushing all atoms
except in the shadow
of your needle,
so you have a very thin slice
of cold atoms falling back,
so that you reduce uncertainty
due to the position
distribution.
And of course,
the time of flight
depends on the
velocity distribution
which is the parameter you
are interested in with such
a temperature.
And if you fit the
experimental signal which
is here, which is a very
good signal to noise,
with a theoretical
fit comparison here,
you find that the temperature is
2.5 micro Kelvin plus or minus
0.6, which I think is the
coldest 3D kinetic temperature
ever measured.
So you have a very
cold temperature.
Remember that the minimum
temperature predicted
for Doppler cooling is 120.
So what is the explanation?
The explanation is
you have sodium atoms
are not two-level atoms.
They have several
Zeeman sublevels.
You have optical pumping
between these amount of levels.
At low intensity, this optical
pumping takes a long time,
so you have long time
general problem in addition
to the lifetime of excited
state which is short.
And long times mean large
non-adiabatic effect,
a large friction mechanism.
That's the general idea.
And I would like now to explain
to you the more specific
example, which we have developed
in Paris with Jean Delibard,
and which we have
called sisyphus cooling.
And I would like to explain
it to you on a simple case
of the 1D molasse Suppose
that you take a 1D molasse--
you take two counterpropagating
laser beams--
but now because the atoms
are not two-level atoms
we have to worry about
the polarization.
And I will take a configuration
leading to a polarization
gradient, and that's easy.
I take two optical linear
polarizations for this beam
and for this beam--
two optical non-linear
polarizations.
At a given place, these
two laser electric field
will be in quadrature, giving
rise to a sigma plus light.
If you move lambda
over 8 to the right,
the two fields will be in
phase, and the polarization
will be linear at 45 degrees.
If you still move
lambda over 8, there
will be, again, in
quadrature, but with a minus
pi over 2k shift instead
of a plus pi over 2.
So they will be sigma minus.
And if you will-- again, you
will have a linear polarization
and then a sigma plus.
So you see that, in
general, in a molasse where
the polarization
changed are different,
you have this
strong polarization
gradient over distances of
the order of the wavelength.
Let me suppose now that
the atoms which are cooled
have two Zeeman sublevels in
the ground state, g minus 1/2
and g plus 1/2.
And let me suppose that
the excited state as a g
equal 3/2 angular momentum, so
we have four Zeeman sublevels
in the upper state--
e minus 3/2, e minus 1/2,
e plus 1/2, e minus 1/2.
And suppose that you
are in a place where
the polarization is sigma plus.
If the polarization
is sigma plus,
you see, easily,
that you have optical
pumping taking atom
from g minus 1/2
and putting them in g plus 1/2.
So all atoms will be optically
pumped in g plus 1/2.
You'll see also that since
the laser frequency is smaller
than the atomic frequency,
the two levels will
be light shifted down,
and because the square
of this Clebsch-Gordan
is 3 times smaller
than the square of
this Clebsch-Gordan,
this light shift will be 3
times smaller than this one.
So the two Zeeman sublevels
will no longer be degenerate.
They will be separated by a
splitting which I call u0,
and which is right shifted.
And all atomic population
will be in g plus 1/2.
Now if I go to another
place where the linear--
the polarization is sigma minus,
the conclusions are reversed.
All atoms will be particularly
pumped in g minus 1/2,
and the g minus
1/2 sub levels will
be shifted 3 times more than
the g plus 1/2 sub level.
So you see that the two sub
levels are shifted like that,
and when you move they are
shifted in the opposite way
and again in the opposite way.
So you see that light
shifts of the Zeeman
sublevels oscillate in
space like that which
a separation over here
which is lambda over 4.
That's your g plus 1/2 level.
That's your g minus 1/2 level.
They oscillate with
an amplitude u0,
and you see that also optical
pumping rates oscillate
because at this point
optical pumping tend
to put atoms in g plus 1/2.
At this point, it tends to
put atoms in g minus 1/2.
So you see that
both light shifts
and optical pumping rates
are modulated especially,
but the important point is
that these two modulations are
correlated.
There is a strong correlation
between the spatial modulation
of light shifts and
the special modulation
of optical pumping rate, and the
correlation results in the fact
that atoms tend to be optically
pumped from the highest
of levels to the lowest one.
So if you now take
a moving atom,
and if you suppose
that the moving
atom starts from the valley--
has been just pumped here.
It starts from the valley
of a potential curve here,
g plus 1/2.
It moves to the right.
It climbs a potential here.
It reaches the top of
the potential hill, where
it has the maximum
probability to be optically
pumped into other sublevels.
That is to say, the bottom
of the valley, and so on.
And you see that because of this
correlation between light shift
and optical pumping rates,
you achieve a situation where
the atom is always
climbing, as Sisyphus
in the Greek mythology.
This is why we call these
cooling mechanisms the Sisyphus
cooling mechanism, because it's
exactly the atomic realization
of the Sisyphus myth.
And you see that
during the climbing,
the kinetic energy is
reduced to the benefit
of the potential energy, and
the gain of potential energy
is then dissipated by
the optical photon which
is emitted.
Because the emitted
photon has an energy which
is larger than the
absorbed photon,
so the potential
energy is dissipated
by spontaneous
emission, and so on.
And you see that at each step,
you decrease the total energy
by an amount u0, and the
total energy of the atom
decreases until the
energy of the atom
reaches a value
corresponding to u0.
And then the atom is trapped.
So you expect that the
temperature obtained
in this way should be
kB T of the order of u0.
That is to say, you remember the
light shift is omega 1 squared
divided by delta, proportional
to the laser intensity I L
and inversely proportional to
the tuning, so that's nice.
When you decrease the
intensity of the light,
you decrease the temperature.
Could you go to zero and
get a zero temperature?
Of course not,
because the gain--
the loss of potential
energy after each cycle,
which is of the order of u0.
If you want to have a cooling,
the loss of potential energy
must be larger than the gain of
kinetic energy to the recoil,
because when the atoms
spontaneously emit a photon
it recoils.
So it has a kinetic
energy at least
h bar squared k squared over 2m.
And you see that if
u0 is too small--
if u0 is smaller
than the recoil--
you can no longer use this
mechanism for cooling.
But you see that now
that this mechanism
linked to temperature which
scale as the recoil energy
and not as h bar gamma.
And of course it had
been possible to make
a complete theory of this
cooling scheme with Yvan
Castin and Jean
Dalibard, and when
predicted that there is a
universal curve giving p
squared average divided
by a unit of h bar
squared k squared versus u0--
the light shift divided
by ER, the recoil energy.
And we predict that you
must have a straight line,
and that a very good agreement
with the experimental results--
you get here a plot of
temperature measured versus
the light shift
in unit of gamma,
and you'll see that the
temperature is really
a linear function
of the light shift.
And the different
points correspond
to different values
of the detuning, which
can vary by a factor of 20.
So we have really checked that
depends only on this parameter
omega 1 squared over the time.
And when the intensity
is too small,
then the curve starts
again to increase.
One interesting thing
about this scheme
is that the lowest
temperature which can achieve
correspond to values
of the parameter,
where the oscillation
frequency of the atom
in the bottom of the
potential wells--
the oscillation frequency is
larger than the damping rate
due to optical pumping.
The oscillation
period is smaller
than the optical pumping time.
You are in a new situation
in this kind of problem,
where the characteristic
time of the external motions
are shorter than the
characteristic time
of the internal motion.
And quantum
mechanically, this mean
that in the potential well
which is here at the bottom
is nearly parabolic.
You have this height
energy levels,
and omega oscillation large
compared to 1 over tau p,
meaning that the splitting
between these energy levels
is larger than the
width of this level
due to the rate of absorption.
This means that we have a
quantisation of atomic motion
in the light potential
associated with the laser beam.
And just a few weeks ago, we
have observed such effects.
We have observed by
an experiment, which
I will describe to you briefly.
We have submitted
a letter where we
have measured in a 1D molar--
which is in blue here--
we have measured the absorption
spectrum of a probe beam in red
here, and we have measured the
absorption of the weak probe
beam versus its
frequency omega probe.
And we have observed
a curve like that
again in absorption--
two curves like that.
And these two sidebands,
we interpret them
as Raman processes.
This one, for example,
we interpret--
we have these
height levels here.
This level is more
populated than this one.
So we have processes
where the atom
in these vibrational levels
can absorb a probe photon,
and make a simulated
emission of a molasse photon,
and go to the v equal 1 level.
And that leads to an
absorption of the probe beam.
We have an absorption
of the probe beam
at your high frequency path.
This is omega for omega
p larger than omega.
And this splitting is just
your oscillation frequency.
And you have, also,
other processes
where you have first an
absorption of the molasse beam
and simulated emission
of a probe beam, which
lead to an amplification of
the probe in the low frequency
path, and this is
what you observe.
And by measuring
this splitting, we
can measure that I think
was the first experimental
determination of the oscillation
frequency of the atom
in the potential well.
And it's nice that,
also, similar results
have been obtained by
quite a different method,
by looking at the
fluorescent light
by Bill Phillips'
group in Gaithersburg.
So we think now we have a
complete experimental evidence
for the existence of
this potential well
and for the quantisation
of atomic motion
in this potential well.
I would like now to give you--
you have seen that you
cannot go below the recoil.
Actually, there's
another scheme which
we have developed
in Paris, and that's
the last part I would
like to discuss now--
the cooling below the
recoil limit, which
has been done with collaboration
with Aspect, Arimondo, Kaiser,
and Vansteenkiste.
If you are interested in
all of these problems,
you can look at
the review paper we
have written with Bill Phillips
for Physics Today in October
1990.
Let me explain, briefly,
what the subrecoil cooling
mechanism is.
It's actually a combination
of two effects--
a velocity selective
coherent population trapping
which select a group of
atoms in a given state--
in a given velocity state--
and prevents these atoms
from absorbing light
by quantum interference
effect of the same type
I described at the
beginning of my lecture--
and second point, the optical
pumping in velocity space
which accumulate atoms
in this dark state.
We have used-- for
doing this calculation
and this experiment--
a transition 1 to 1,
g equal 1 to g equal 1.
You see, here, there are
six Zeeman sublevels--
the three in the upper state,
the three in the lower state.
And the important point is that
this Clebsch-Gordan coefficient
is equal to zero.
So if you start with atoms which
are equally distributed here,
here, and here--
if you excite these atoms with
two counterpropagating beams,
sigma plus and sigma minus,
they are optically pumped
here and here.
And from these two
levels, if they absorb,
again, your sigma
minus photon, they
can never come back to g0
because this Clebsch-Gordan
coefficient is equal to zero.
So after a few optical
pumping cycles,
the atoms are just circulating
between these three states.
And we have a pure system
called lambda configuration,
because we have a
pure system of two sub
levels in the ground state and
sub level in the excited state.
And now we can have nice
interference effect,
because suppose that now--
I will show you that
these cooling schemes
lead to temperature
which are smaller
than the recoil temperature.
Now the de Broglie
wavelength becomes larger
than the laser
wavelength, and we
have to specify quantum numbers
not only for the internal state
but also for the
atomic motion state.
Let me call e0 P a state where
the atom is in the upper state
e0 with the momentum p along z.
And let me consider the
g minus p minus h bar k--
in the atom in g minus with
the momentum p minus h bar k.
Because of angular
momentum conservation,
for going from g
minus to e0 you have
to absorb the sigma plus photon.
Since the sigma plus photon
is coming that way, when
the atom absorbs the
sigma plus photon,
it gains the momentum h bar k.
So going from p minus h bar
k and absorbing plus h bar k,
it goes to e0 P. So
the two states which
are coupled by sigma plus are g
minus p minus h bar k and e0 P.
The same argument shows that
for going from g plus to e0 P,
you have to start from
g plus p plus h bar k
because now you have to absorb
the sigma minus photon, which
carries the momentum
is minus h bar k.
So you have to start from p plus
h bar k in order to get to p.
So these two states are coupled
to this one by sigma plus
and by sigma minus,
and these two numbers
are your two Clebsch-Gordan
coefficients.
So if I take a state which is a
linear combination of these two
states with the
plus sign here, 1
over square root of g minus
p minus h bar k plus g plus p
plus h bar k, you see
that the amplitude
of absorption of sigma
plus is equal to 1
over square root of 2.
The amplitude of absorption
of sigma minus is minus 1
over square of 2, and the
two absorption amplitudes
interfere destructively.
We are exactly in the
situation I described before.
Such a state is not
couple by the laser light.
See, this is why I call
it cnc non couple--
the matrix element of the
laser atom interaction
Hamiltonian between c and
cp and e0p is equal to 0.
Of course, if you
take the minus sign--
you take the orthogonal
linear combination,
now you have to add 1 over
square of 2 minus minus
plus 1 over square over 2.
The two amplitudes
interfere constructively,
and this state is coupled.
So you have a non-coupled state.
Now how can you select
one non-coupled state
from the other one?
Now this state is the linear
superposition of two states.
Have they the same energy?
If I suppose that the magnetic
field is equal to zero,
the two Zeeman energies
of g minus and g
plus are equal to
zero, but now you
have to include
in the Hamiltonian
the kinetic energy Hamiltonian,
p squared divided by 2m.
And the kinetic
energy of this state
is p minus h bar k
squared divided by 2l,
and the kinetic
energy of this state
is p plus h bar k
squared divided by 2l.
And you see that the
two kinetic energy
are the same only
if p is equal to 0,
because these two number are
equal only if p equal to zero.
So there is only one state which
is stationary, which does not
involve in time, because it
is a superposition of two
states with the same energy.
It's a state p equal 0.
This is the velocity selection.
As soon as P is
not equal to zero,
the two states have
not the same energy--
the phase factor appearing
in the revolution exponents
are not the same.
And in other words, your kinetic
energy Hamiltonian coupled
with non-coupled state
to the coupled state,
with a matrix element which is
proportional to e kp over m.
So we have now everything.
We can now explain
how things proceed.
An atom in the
non-coupled state c
ncp with three
different forms 0,
can absorb light and
go to the upper state.
Then it makes a
spontaneous emission.
But a spontaneous emission
produces a random change
of momentum, because the
spontaneous emission photon can
be emitted in any direction.
So after the fluorescent
cycle, the change of momentum
make that the
atoms can fall back
in a state, in concept which
has a non-zero overlap,
with the states NCP prime
with p prime smaller than p,
and so on.
So you see that you can progress
towards p equal to zero,
and you see that the smaller p--
the longer the time
spent in cnc of p--
because the smaller will
be the coupling between PNC
and [INAUDIBLE] introduced by
the kinetic energy Hamiltonian.
So the longer the
interaction time t theta,
the smaller the range
delta p around p
equals zero of value of p for
the state CNC of p, which p
is smaller than delta p--
in which the atom can remain
trapped during the interaction
time.
So you see that
by that scheme you
can accumulate the atom
in a small velocity
interval, which decreases when
you increase interaction time.
So there is no limit to
the temperature which
can be obtained
by such a scheme,
and you see that the atom will
pile up in a double momentum
state cnc of p, which p is
smaller than delta p and delta
p decreasing-- you control
the delta p decreases as 1
over square root of theta.
We have observed,
actually, this effect
by letting an atomic beam
of helium crossing 2 sigma
plus and sigma minus
counterpropagating laser beam
and by analyzing the momentum
distribution of the atom
after the interaction
zone, and that
is the results we obtained.
That's the momentum
distribution of the atom
before the interaction zone.
That's the distribution
after the interaction zone.
And you see that we get two
peaks, because the atom is
in a double momentum state.
So the probability to
find the value of p
is either p minus h bar k
or p plus h bar k with p
smaller than plus
or minus delta p.
And the fact that you reach the
sub recoil cooling temperature
is revealed by the fact that
the width of these two peaks
is smaller than the splitting
two h bar k between them.
Actually, in this experiment,
we reached a temperature
of 2 micro Kelvin, where
the recoil temperature is
4 micro Kelvin.
That means that the de Broglie
wavelength is 1.4 micro Kelvin,
whereas the laser wavelength
which reduced to do the cooling
was 0.08 micro Kelvin.
We did this experiment three
years ago or two years ago
with a thermal beam
having a velocity
of 1 kilometer per second.
Now we have a cloud
of stopped atoms.
We are planning to--
these atoms are very slow.
We are planning to
leave them for--
and cross a 2D
configuration of laser beam,
and produce a
two-dimensional dark state.
We hope, within a few months,
it could give us the possibility
to reach the nano Kelvin
[INAUDIBLE] in the temperature.
I would like to
briefly end my talk
by giving you two applications
of this scheme of cold atoms.
Now, the last part of my talk.
The first one is the so-called
Zacharias atomic fountain.
Up to now, two research
fountains have been achieved.
One in Stanford on sodium
and one in Paris on cesium.
The idea is that to have very
good atomic clocks we must
have a long interaction time.
Usually, atomic clocks
are done with atomic beams
with 100 meters
per second atoms.
Now we have atomic trace, we
have a much longer interaction
time.
In our experiment, the
velocity of the cesium atoms
is only 2 centimeters
per second.
So what we can do,
we can take atoms,
and we can throw
them like that--
having them passing
through a cavity
once in the up direction and
one in the down direction.
And when they pass it
in the cavity twice,
you get two pulse--
the experiment of two
pulse of microwave,
and you can observe
Ramsey fringes.
And the time between
the two pulses
is observed at 0.3 seconds to
be compared with the 1 to 10
millisecond time
of flight achieved
in the best atomic clock
with thermal atoms.
So we can hope to gain two
or three of those magnitudes,
with respect to the width of
the cesium clock transition.
How to launch the atom?
Of course, the
simple thing would
be to apply radiation
pressure on the junction,
but here we heat the atom
by momentum diffusion.
So a much more clever
scheme is to use,
for the two vertical
beams of the molasse,
two different frequencies--
omega minus delta omega
and omega plus delta omega.
So that when you go
to the moving frame,
such that v equal
delta omega over k--
because of the Doppler
effect in the moving frame,
the two beams will have the
same apparent frequency,
so you will have
a moving molasses.
And the atom will be locked
to this moving molasses,
so they will move
while remaining cool.
So we can launch the atom
while keeping them cold--
keeping the same temperature.
That's an example of that detail
of the experimental setup.
We have here about
5 centimeters,
because in our experiment
the vacuum was such
that we couldn't send the
atom at a distance higher
than 5 centimeters
above the cavity.
But anyway, that's an
example of Ramsey fringes
which are obtained.
And the bottom point,
the central fringe,
has only 2.03 Hertz, to be
compared with a few hundred
Hertz of the atomic clocks--
you current atomic clocks.
So you see we have already--
as far as the width
is concerned--
nearly two orders of
magnitude improvement
in the precision of the clock.
The second example
concerns the fact that when
you go to a low velocity--
two cold atoms, you
have low velocity.
Low velocity means that you
have long de Broglie wavelength.
And now there is
a new field which
is studying physics, which is
a wave aspect of atomic motion.
Atomic motion appears.
You have to consider the
atom now as a wave, not only
as a particle, but as a wave.
And there are new fields
which are emerging, which
are called atomic
interferometry, atomic optics,
and which are
studied extensively
in different labs-- including
Dave Pritchard's lab here,
Munich Lab in Kostanz, and
[INAUDIBLE] in Stanford.
And in Paris, we are
devising an experiment.
We were using what we call
a gravitational cavity.
We would like to make--
we start with a parabolic
mirror like that,
and we form at the surface
of the parabolic mirror
an evanescent wave which
is detuned to the blue.
The laser frequency is larger
than the atomic frequency,
so the light shift is positive.
Since the light shift
is positive and decrease
exponentially with
the distance, we
have a potential
barrier when you
approach the surface
of the mirror, which
increased exponentially.
And if the initial
velocity of the atom
is smaller than the
height of the barrier,
the atom will be reflective.
Of course, that experiment
has been done already
by two groups and,
in particular,
using a grazing incidents.
Because if you use the thermal
beam, the velocity is larger.
You have to use a
very small angle,
so that the velocity along
this direction is small.
But now we have slow
atoms, we can just
let them drop on the surface.
We have a molasse, or
magneto optical trap,
and we release the beam.
And the atoms fall, and
they fall like that--
as a [INAUDIBLE].
And because such an effect
has been already observed
by at least two people--
but since the first experiment,
we are using a plain mirror,
the atoms are leaving
the illuminated zone.
If you are using a
parabolic mirror,
then the atoms are trapped also
in the transverse direction,
and you can get a stable motion.
Actually, you can solve
Schrodinger equation
exactly when you take
the gravitational field
and the boundary condition,
which is the parabola that
can be solved exactly.
And such, for
example, an example
of quantum mechanical solution
of Schrodinger equation,
which we call a quantum
mechanical mode.
And we hope to be able
to observe such modes,
and we hope to be able to put
more than one atom in a given
mode.
Because if we are able to put
one atom in a given mode, then
because of the Bose
effect, Bose factor,
if there are n atoms in
a mole, the farther atom
would like to join with the
probability n plus 1, instead
of the other modes
which are [INAUDIBLE]..
So we'll have a tendency
of atoms to cluster
in already occupied modes.
That would not be
Bose condensation.
That would be a
simpler manifestation
of the Bose factor.
I will stop here, and I
would like now to conclude.
I hope to have convinced
you, by comparing
the first part of my talk and
the second part of my talk,
that there are new
physical mechanisms using
old well known effects--
such as optical
pumping, light shift,
coherent population trapping,
Hanle effect, et cetera--
which allow one now to cool
atoms down to 1 micro Kelvin
and to reach de Broglie
wavelengths larger
than the laser wavelength.
I think that these results
provide a great stipulation
for investigating the
application of cold atoms
in various domains of
physics, such as atomic clock,
atomic frequency standard,
atomic interferometry, atom
optics--
and also a great
simulation for trying
to get a still
better understanding
of the atom-photon interaction.
I hope to have convinced
you that the fact
that the atomic
motion is quantized,
prevents us now from thinking
of an atom at a point.
We have to consider it not only
as a point, but also as a wave.
And we have to solve
Schrodinger equation
for the center of mass motion.
Among the present
theoretical development,
one that seems very promising
is a development called
quantum Monte Carlo
approach, which
tried to apply to this kind
of problem quantum Monte Carlo
simulation which
preserve the quantum
features of the
problem, and which
would be extremely
useful for understanding
what happened not only in 1D--
which I have mostly
explained today--
but also at 2D and
3D which correspond
to a real experiment.
Finally, I would like to
acknowledge my colleagues
in Paris who have
done all this work.
In the Paris group, there
are four permanent people
in addition to me.
A Aspect was with me since
1984 and left last October
to Institut Optique.
He got a new
position there, and I
think you probably
have heard of his lab
lecture a few weeks ago.
He has been replaced
by [INAUDIBLE],, coming
from Helsinki.
There are two other permanent
people from CNRS, Jean Delibard
and Christophe Salamon.
These four people, Robert
Kaiser, Natalie Vansteenkiste.
Delphine Grison, Yvan
Castin have already
finished their thesis,
and they left the lab.
I hope that Yvan
Castin could come back.
Olivia Emile, Francois
Bardou, [INAUDIBLE] Louis,
Pierre Desboilles, and P
Bouyer are doing their PhD.
And we have benefited from the
various visitors in the lab
during the last few years.
I mentioned here only
a few visitors will
spend at least six months--
[INAUDIBLE] Metcalf, [INAUDIBLE]
Phillips, I. Silvera,
E. Arimondo, Chris
Gerz, Chris Westbrook--
and also two other people
from France, Andre Clairon
and [INAUDIBLE] Guellati.
Thank you very much
for your attention.
INTERVIEWER: Thank you.
Are you open to
questions or comments?
[INAUDIBLE]
STUDENT: It's a gravitational
cavity [INAUDIBLE] will you
expect the atoms to lose energy
by dissipation as they bounce
off the surface and then
settle right down on--
TANNOUDJI: If the
laser detuned--
if the laser frequency is
detuned far, far to the blue,
then the bouncing will
be perfectly elastic.
There will be no
dissipation at all.
There will be a pure
potential reflection.
The problem that you have
small absorption probability,
and we have to reduce
this as much as possible.
Because once you
have an absorption--
a real absorption process--
a scattering process--
then first you
have a momentum kick which can
of course take the atom away.
And you have also destruction
of the spatial coherence length.
STUDENT: So I was
thinking, if you
could adjust the
dissipation properly,
then you could settle down
into the bottom of the well
and get Bose-Einstein
condensation,
but it might impossible.
TANNOUDJI: No.
It depends what you
are interested in.
If you are interested in the
wave aspect of atomic motion,
you are interested to have
long coehrence length,
and we have to avoid
spontaneous emission,
because spontaneous emission can
be considered as a measurement
process to destroy atomic wells.
So we have to avoid
the resonant processes,
so we have to go far
away from resonance.
So that needs to have
a powerful laser.
Of course, we can focus a
laser as much as possible,
but if the bright spot is too
small, then the probability
that the atom escapes is large.
So there is a trade off
between the intensity
and how far you can detune.
And we are planning to use
in our experiment [INAUDIBLE]
we hope, in the first step, to
be able to observe 50 bounce.
INTERVIEWER: Dave?
STUDENT: Well, Claude
as an experimentalist,
I feel maybe that this is kind
of an end to an era by which I
mean that for 70 years or
so what we've been trying
to do in atomic physics is to
get greater control over atoms.
So first, there
were atomic beams
to isolate them from
the rest of the world,
and then resonance techniques
to control the internal states
and optical buffing.
And now here we finally
got the external motion
quantized and basically
under control.
I mean, what is there to do now?
TANNOUDJI: I think we are now
entering a new period where
we should use these cold
atoms to make new physics.
One example is atomic
interferometry.
Obviously, atomic
interferometry,
if we can increase the surface
of the interfering arms,
that provides
improvement factors
which are really
incredible, with respect
to light interferometry.
Another exciting field is
to these quantum statistical
effects.
What happens if you have
more than one atom in a given
quantum mechanical mode?
So I think also collision.
Collision process
with cold atoms,
we were discussing that
a few hours before.
That also provides
a lot of new things,
so I think there is a lot
of exciting developments
we can hopefully expect
in the next few years.
Also, I think the
moral of this story
is that to have a
field progressing,
we must control everything.
Because as I mentioned
in my lecture
in Washington, in the
1917 paper of Einstein,
he was saying that one
should pay the same atom
to the conservation
of inner momentum
than to the
conservation of energy,
even if it is less spectacular.
He was saying that at a time
when nobody was considering
momentum, and I think that--
obviously, the whole field
of laser cooling and trapping
is a beautiful illustration
of this sentiment.
And I think that the last
recent development in the field
shows that one should also pay
the same attention to angular
momentum, because it's really
angular momentum is clearly
involved in this new mechanism.
If the atom had no
angular momentum state,
we couldn't have the
Sisyphus cooling,
we couldn't have coherent
population trapping.
So I think we need everything.
I think it's important
to have a control
of all degrees of
freedom if we want
to make new exciting physics.
Of course, it has been
a lot of excitement
to understand this
mechanism, but I think
now we have to go further.
INTERVIEWER: I just did want
to mention that the lecture is
being videotaped, so that you're
concern that the field has been
exhausted, and there
may not be anything left
to do has been recorded.
If you have second
thoughts on that,
we might be able to remove it.
It's just that-- actually,
this may be a good omen.
Because when an
authority in the field
says the field is
finished, that's
generally when things just
open up a fresh [INAUDIBLE]..
You, Michael.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
TANNOUDJI: We just
add, to the Hamiltonian
to p squared over 2m, minus mgz.
So it's a very simple
Hamiltonian-- p
squared over 2m minus mgz.
The only thing, we have
a boundary condition,
the wave function,
corresponding to parabola.
And the problem is
completely solvable
in parabolic coordinates.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
TANNOUDJI: No, it's potential
energy which is minus mgz.
That's all.
In this problem--
in that problem--
in that specific problem.
INTERVIEWER: It's the same thing
as applying an electric field.
Yes?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
TANNOUDJI: Excuse me?
TANNOUDJI: Oh,
it's by polishing.
with a sphere, [INAUDIBLE]
They don't touch the glass.
You know, the glass is
covered by a layer of light,
and the atom is reflected
by light before reaching--
if the atom sticks--
it the atoms sticks to
the wall, we are lost.
Of course, there is another
interesting field which
I have not mentioned here--
about collision of these
cold atoms and surface.
So, a lot of open questions.
But here in this
experiment, we are
avoiding any contact between
the atom and the surface.
We reflect the atom before
it reaches the surface.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
TANNOUDJI: Nobody has still
been able to make a [INAUDIBLE]
theory to what happened
in the 3D molasse--
complicated because you
imagine easily how complicated
is the field polarization
in space when you
combine three standing rates?
Some calculations started to
be done by Monte Carlo method.
And I think that we have
some in collaboration
between the temperature and
the various directions-- some
coupled, yes.
It is strange because we
have a simple proportionality
factor between the
temperature at 3D
and the temperature at 1D, which
seems that there are, perhaps,
simple explanations
which have to be found.
STUDENT: If you have
more than one atom mode,
is the interaction between them
a chip-to-resonance frequency
[INAUDIBLE]?
TANNOUDJI: Sure, that's a big
problem for trying to have.
For example, in the
magneto optical trap,
to put many, many atoms.
But here what is
nice is we are not
working with the lowest mode.
We are not trying to put
atoms in the lowest energy
mode, small mode.
We are trying to put atoms in a
large end mode, highly excited
mode, where on the
average the atoms are
more distant than
in the lower state.
We are trying to do a
laser mode with atoms
with [INAUDIBLE] waves.
You know, a laser
mode in a cavity
is a mode with n,
which can be very high.
We are trying to
do the same thing
with replacing optical
waves by [INAUDIBLE] waves.
But what we would like to
find, and is very exciting,
is scheme for having the
equivalent of the [INAUDIBLE]
filter, which selects
one mode, which
introduces loss for all
modes except one or a few.
So we have to find the
equivalent of the mode
selector.
INTERVIEWER: One more question.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
TANNOUDJI: You mean
what is the prediction?
Yes.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
TANNOUDJI: Excuse me.
I do not understand
your question.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
TANNOUDJI: You have to
control the magnetic fields,
so that the magnetic
shift is smaller than u0
at the light shift.
That's easy with shield or
with compensating cores.
But when you are compensating
the magnetic field,
we have a theoretical expression
giving the lowest temperature
which can be reached
by Sisyphus cooling,
and it's of the order
of 3 or 4 [INAUDIBLE]
of the 3 or 4 h bar k.
So we get the minimum p which
is about 3 recoil momentum.
That is the minimum which can
be obtained by Sisyphus cooling.
The other scheme, you can
go as slow as you want.
But you have a state which
is the linear superposition
of state deferring
by their momentum
and their internal state.
INTERVIEWER: OK, we
appreciate this talk.
Actually, I somewhat
share Dave's feelings,
because it looks like just about
everything that can be done
has been done.
But I also believe
myself when I say
that this is still a beginning.
In any case, we appreciate
very much you're
explaining this work to us
so beautifully and clearly.
And thank you.
[APPLAUSE]